[Music]
use a probe to approximate the deepest
depth of needle penetration that will be
needed
cut the depth stop sheath to the
appropriate graduation ensure that the
depth stop will allow the needle to
penetrate the meniscus at the deepest
portion of the tear use the sheath as a
protective entry cannula for entry of
the meniscal needle into the joint space
pull back on the depth stop sheath until
it engages fully onto the handle ensure
that the switch is forward in the
freewheel position and pierced through
the meniscus use the needle markings to
ensure the proper depth of penetration
to place the first implant advance the
trigger forward to prepare the device
for implant deployment then pull back
and release the trigger to deploy an
implant withdraw the needle from the
meniscus move the switch backwards to
the ratchet position to tension the
suture the red dot should be exposed
pull back on the device and reel the
thumb wheel to tension the suture and
ensure that the implant is set move the
switch forward into the freewheel
position to create slack in the suture
target the position of the next implant
on the meniscus to place the second
implant and fix the stitch again pierce
the meniscus rotate the device to full
revolutions engaging the knotless
fixation advance the trigger and then
pull back and release to deploy the next
implant withdraw the needle from the
meniscus move the switch into the
ratchet position pull back to tighten
the stitch and reel the suture in to
remove excess slack move the switch into
the freewheel position
repeat the steps to create multiple
sequential stitches pierce the meniscus
rotate the device twice advance the
trigger to reset pull and release the
trigger to deploy an implant withdraw
the needle from the meniscus and tension
the stitch continue creating sequential
stitches until the meniscal running
repair is complete after the last stitch
remove the sequent meniscal repair
device from the joint load the suture
cutter onto the suture outside of the
joint holding the cutter perpendicular
and the suture taut load the suture into
the cutter slot rotate the cutter shaft
to align axially with the suture keep
the thumb resting on the blue thumb rest
and keeping the suture taut slide the
suture cutter down the suture and into
the joint until flush with the meniscus
when ready to cut the suture press the
red lever
the stitch configuration shown here is
the sequential meniscal running stitch
the most important benefit of the
sequent meniscal repair system is its
multiple sequential stitch capability
providing the versatility to fix
numerous types of repairs the sequent
meniscal repair device allows the user
to change portals or create a new
sequence of stitches during the surgery
and still use the same device when using
this technique the user should ensure
that there are enough implants remaining
in the device to create the desired
number of stitches if not a new device
should be opened cut the suture flush to
the meniscus remove the device from the
joint and pull out enough suture from
the needle to tie a knot tie a figure of
8 leaving approximately 10 millimeters
of suture tail move the switch back to
the ratchet position and reel the suture
so that the knot is drawn into the
starting implant the device is now reset
[Music]